i don't like how casual you're being
about this is unnatural are you and
where are we man happy falcon in the
winter soldier day folks in this episode
our heroes go clubbing
meet up with some old friends consider
this your spoiler warning i'm carlos
bustamante and this is et canada's nerf
[Music]
we start with everyone's favorite new
addition to the mcu the captain america
cosplayer john walker
in his attempts to track down carly
morgenthau and the flag smashers
he is supposed to be the sentinel of
liberty but is acting more like a
terrible school principal mixed with an
entitled celebrity
trying to get out of a parking ticket
do you know who i am
[Music]
yes i do and i don't care nobody has any
idea where the flag smashers are or how
they got their hands on the super
soldier serum so sam and bucky go visit
the one guy they know
might have some leads
those days are over can i just say i was
so happy zemo led with that i mean
he knew it wouldn't work but you gotta
shoot your shot you know
anyway after bucky orchestrates the most
casual prison break in history
zebo's gotta stop off at the old garage
to pick up a few things and pretty soon
the boys are jet-setting off to majapur
to get in contact with one of zemo's
shady associates a criminal
named selby by the way did you know zemo
is like
loaded he's a baron after all and i love
tony stark
r.i.p but he never hooked anyone up with
a suit like this
if we have to do something about this
i'm the only one who looks like a pimp
only an american would assume a fashion
forward black man looks like a dim you
look exactly like the man you're
supposed to be playing
a sophisticated charming african rake
named conrad mack
aka the smiling tiger for reference
smiling tiger in the comics looks like
this so maybe not like exactly
comics accurate major poor looks like a
neon lit spring break
all the way down to the questionable
drinks honestly if it weren't for all
the people trying to kill you it seems
like a pretty good time though i guess
if i was friends with a winter soldier
i'd feel a bit safer sam mind you seems
a little put off with how easily bucky
slips back into a murder machine though
[Music]
you could
looks like zemo's connections are legit
selby gives him the lowdown on the super
soldier serum
and has a power broker who basically
controls all of magikor
had a scientist named wilford nagel to
recreate the serum for him
side note if you're ever impersonating a
dangerous criminal while meeting with
another dangerous criminal in a lawless
foreign country
make sure you put your phone on silent
cash what i tell you about the cheerios
i don't have time for this sam i'm sorry
let me call you back
sad no sam
kill them this little mishap gets the
guys on the run
from every bounty hunter in the
immediate vicinity until they're rescued
by none other than former shield agent
and current fugitive from the us
government sharon carter sharon's been
hiding out in madrid for the last few
years and has done
pretty well for herself as a stolen fine
art dealer among other mysterious things
however it's been more out of necessity
and the experience of being hunted down
by her former country after helping out
a bunch of superheroes
has kind of soured her on the idea of
ever helping out again
look you know the whole hero thing is a
joke right
before you were his pet psychopath you
were mr america
cat's best friend oh she's kind of awful
now
only kind of awful i guess because she
helps anyway and gets the guys over to
the elusive dr nagel
who tells him how he worked for both
hydra and the cia
on a new perfected version of the super
soldier serum
which was unjustly taken from the blood
of isaiah bradley
however nothing gets in the way of
scientific progress much like getting
blipped out of existence for five years
by an alien warlord with magic jewelry
and when he got back
it was a power broker who wanted to fund
nagel's continued work
that is until carly morgenthau stole 20
vials of the stuff and started playing
super powered robin hood around the
globe
and just when you thought things could
not get worse for the good doctor
this happens guys we're seriously out of
time here
what did you do
[Music]
you know when i was a kid i kind of
wanted to be a scientist but now i'm
glad i changed my
i wasn't smart enough we get to see zemo
do some pretty badass stuff here
including
finally putting on his fancy purple mask
to waste some hapless thugs
and steal a classic pontiac as a getaway
car on top of that
sam and bucky give us a cheeky little
civil war throwback
you're not gonna move your seat up are
you no
even though sharon helped the guys out
here her motivations aren't exactly
clear
what's her end game sorry meanwhile the
flag smashers have been in latvia trying
to help sick refugees
as well as lithuania stealing much
needed supplies the grc have been
stockpiling
and though her intentions seem noble
enough carly's methods
a little suss put your seatbelt on
now
there's still people in there this is
the only language these people
understand
on the trail of carly sam bucky and zemo
head to latvia
when they arrive but he notices they're
being tailed leaving to investigate he
discovers that they're being followed by
an old friend
io of wakanda's dora milage and her
target
is baron zemo is the white wolf going to
go up against the people that saved his
life
is baron zemo somehow playing sam and
bucky for his own nefarious ends
probably will battlestar realize that
his friend john walker
kind of an [ __ ] let's talk about it
in the comments below we're halfway
through the falcon and the winter
soldier
and i want to know if it's meeting or
exceeding your expectations so far
thank you so much for watching we've got
a lot more videos so please like and
subscribe
and i'll see you next time